governor steve sisselek announced this
today that our statewide paws will
continue
past the new year this comes as nevada
continues to see
startling covet 19 case numbers and
deaths 8 news now reporter madison
kimbrough joins us live tonight
with the latest on the governor's plan
madison
yes governor systolak made the
announcement that he is going to extend
the statewide pause until january 15th
also stating that there's going to be
another surge coming from thanksgiving
according to our latest statistics
nevadan is testing positive for covet
every 40 seconds that's 45
cases in 30 minutes and every hour and
15 minutes
nevadan dies from cloven we are just
starting to see the effects of the virus
from thanksgiving as governor sisolak
has decided to extend the statewide
pause
he implemented in november to january
15.
this means capacity in most places will
continue to be capped off at 25 percent
the governor also mentioned that the
pfizer vaccine will arrive on monday for
nevadans
as over 2500 people in our state have
died from the virus
the governor implementing another health
mitigation measure that being a new
eviction moratorium
tomorrow i will sign a directive that
will place a moratorium
on most residential evictions in nevada
with an effective date
and time of 1201 am on december 15th
originally governor systolak put a
residential eviction moratorium in place
in the early stages of the pandemic
but now since we are currently in the
depths of our most dangerous surge
the governor is reinstating a moratorium
until march 31st
when people are evicted it is impossible
to stay home
they are out looking for jobs and
housing to desperately save their
families
they will spread covet 19
unintentionally
because they have no options local
officials are also concerned about our
shelters and other congregate housing
options being overrun with homeless
families
we spoke to some las vegas who believe
that sysolac's plan is what's best for
our state
i think it's a good and measured
response we're all trying our best
to adjust to this pandemic i'd rather be
safe than
sorry i feel safer and
so i know that the numbers continue to
ramp up and so
i mean i think he's doing the right
thing
now in his press conference the governor
also touched on drug use in our state
saying that there has been a 50 percent
increase in opioid and fentanyl drug
related deaths within
this nine-month period reporting live
madison kimbrough
8 news now